like okay you took me out you bought me
things whatever like people do that all
the time
okay
can i ask a question
me i guess
why are you being so mean why are you so
mad
i mean just like listen to the vocal
frame man i guess
here we go let's do it
all right so we're going to bring luke
on luke uh i i almost want to call a
nice guy luke because uh producer lee's
been talking about how nice this guy is
yo luke what is going on thanks for
coming on the show
uh so
well it can't be going that well i'm
calling you right yeah yeah what are you
calling us
so it looks like so if you guys are new
to this let me just frame it a little
bit better for you so this is a segment
called ghosted people call in
because they get ghosted by somebody
that they like it's not always dudes
sometimes it's women too but they get
ghosted by somebody that they like and
they want the radio station to find out
why for them and call that person in
case it was like an accident or
something like that and the station says
look if you guys want to go out again
then we'll pay for your date so
um it's a good way for them to create
content i think it's really interesting
the way this one went down but just
listen up
it looks like i've been ghosted oh no no
okay now that is the name of the segment
so if you hadn't been it would have been
a bit of a surprise um what happened
what's going on tell the story with
carmen
okay so i know the answer is always like
uh no clue why and then it's revealed
later that there are like many red flags
yeah you know whatever person it was but
like i can honestly say there's
absolutely nothing in my mind that
justifies
me not hearing from carmen
okay both of them
i will warn you everybody says that too
they say i don't have any red flags and
it turns out they are an actual red flag
so okay so tell me tell us about carmen
okay sure so uh we met in late september
at a friend of ours like a musical
friends get together
and we kind of just
haven't stopped talking since then um
you know we got to the point you know
like it kind of gradually builds up we
got to the point we were talking like
almost every single day and just about
nothing about nonsense just like
stupid stuff like you just text each
other constantly um we went to we went
to niagara on the lake for some wine
tasting back in october and okay so this
segment
it's uploaded december 7th he said that
they went for wine tasting back in
october at niagara on the lake for those
who
don't know where that is that's wine
country here in ontario
um it's not close i'm going to say it's
about an hour hour and a half
um
in the niagara peninsula it's a wine
grown region they've got all these
wineries and estates and hotels and bed
and breakfasts and stuff like that it's
a cool place to go it's you know um
we often go there a lot with the guys at
the supercar club because the niagara
escarpment's there so there's a lot of
winding roads that kind of go up and
down the escarpment so it's a fun drive
um a lot of dudes will take girls there
hoping to get somewhere to impress
them with the winery or the wine tasting
or whatever so this guy you know meets a
girl in september takes her out for a
wine tasting at niagara on the lake
about an hour outside of the city i
don't know if you spent the night over
there or try to but you definitely
dropped some bank on her to try to
impress her um but just listen up and i
definitely thought that that meant we
were moving you know in the right
direction and it's moving forward
so um i actually left her out around a
month ago for her birthday
when we went to her favorite restaurant
on danforth and and got her i got her
this necklace she's been telling me
about
and
she just stopped checking out my calls
and texts a couple weeks ago
oh and at first i was gonna let it go i
was like no this is you know this is not
it's not cool and i think i deserve a
response because it's not like we went
out one time if we had we were talking
all the time
okay all right well listen here's what
we're gonna do
so dude's talking all the time to her
takes her to niagara on the lake for a
wine tasting takes her out to dinner at
our favorite restaurant and buys her a
necklace for her birthday this is what
happens we're we're gonna we're gonna
call carmen and see what happened i'm
gonna guess something happened on that
date
something happened on that day i mean
no
no or maybe the necklace was too much i
don't know maybe i don't know okay okay
let's instead of speculating we'll find
out next jax have some water and when we
come back we're going to do some ghosted
hang on
all right so we want to introduce you to
luke who's wondering why carmen ghosted
him now luke met carmen at a party in
september um and you know they kind of
you know hit it off and started talking
and it's the kind of talk where it's
like you can't wait for that person's
name to pop up on your phone right
you're excited and you're not talking
about anything in particular you know
with your friends you're telling your
friends about it they're like what are
you guys talking about you're like i
don't even know i just really like them
just anything anything at all now luke
took carmen out for her birthday dinner
a couple weeks ago
and at that time presented her luke am i
am i correct to say this with a necklace
yeah okay a necklace or a locket with
your picture in it that's true
that i knew she liked yeah and then you
haven't heard anything from her
a since yeah and like i said i know how
these things go if you're waiting to
hear something about me that's crazy but
there's nothing here that went wrong on
my hand
i'm a stand-up guy you know yeah
there's nothing that went wrong on my
end i'm a stand-up guy well let's see
what carmen thinks of this stand-up nice
guy i just i really like carmen and i'm
hoping there's a good reason for it i'm
not sure who's gonna have a harder time
getting through this luke or jacks with
her coughing horses i swallowed water
the wrong way i'm not doing well that's
okay we'll get you a sippy cup
okay all right so we're gonna call we
call carbon jacks are you sure you're
gonna be okay i don't know
all right all right let's give carbon a
call
hi carmen
yeah this time hey it's adam and welcome
jack from 99 virgin radio how are you hi
hello i'm okay how are you we're great
we're great we're just calling about a
guy uh named luke we understand that you
and luke were big time communicators but
that you're no longer communicating and
we're just wondering why and what
exactly are you trying to communicate
with me about regarding luke
well i just wanted to know why you
didn't why you guys aren't talking
anymore
um i just haven't gotten back to him
like what's the big deal did we really
like call you to ask me to get back to
them is that what this says
awesome stuff yeah no it was just no i
listen we bombarded you early in the
morning i get it i completely get it
yeah like i think i think what it is is
that like you know i certainly feel like
maybe luke felt like there was a
connection there and then you know that
and then you you haven't gone back to
him and like you guys went out for lunch
for dinner or whatever your birthday
okay well sometimes people take a while
to get back to one another when you're
just friends like i don't know what kind
of connection he thought we had like i
don't know what this is supposed to be
or what but like luke needs to just like
comment down because it's seriously
annoying
so
so are you saying luke aren't dating
um dating why dating why because he took
me out for my birthday are we five
friends do that okay um and also not for
nothing like i started seeing somebody
so
super inappropriate
and you can just like um let me just
like go ahead and tell luke that okay
just tell him tell him that since he's
clearly got some heart feelings
i'll tell him all that luke
friend
random carmen what are you are you
kidding me
like we we've talked basically every day
we went out every weekend
like i took you okay
okay you know what you can just stop
right there um like are you seriously
ambushing me on the radio right now is
this your your big plan really
and you know what like honestly like i'm
a little shocked but like the more i
think about it like seriously we have
not even banged so like i don't even
know why you thought this was like
anything serious like okay you took me
out you bought me things whatever like
people do that all the time
okay
september october november december 7th
four months
dude was chasing this chick no intimacy
blowing money trying to impress her
taking her niagara on the lake buying
her dinner on her birthday and giving
her a gold necklace or whatever it was
that he handed over her way and this is
the way that she's talking to him
what do we talk about with alpha seed
and beta need right
guess who she's with right now alpha c
guess who this guy was beta need can i
ask a question
me i guess
why are you being so mean why are you so
mad
um i am not mad and i am not being mean
i am being direct and there is a
difference and when you are direct
like this should not happen to you so
i'm a little put off so were you direct
with luke when you let him take you out
for lunch were you direct with luke when
you let him take you out for lunch and
buy you something like yeah i'd be
direct with anyone who wants to buy me
something go ahead we can be friends you
can find me stuff and then you can just
keep it moving
well lucky luke i i guess
i i think i see what happened here yes
what happened here did somebody i was
yeah i was mister right now until a
better guy came along you know i was
like a placeholder you got it
i'll take an help for this one
i should have seen this coming uh good
luck with your new man though
yeah you know what no no luke we're not
just going to stop it there um because
you're trying to make me look bad so
it's not really my fault that you
assumed something was there that wasn't
there so maybe this is a little lesson
for you looky read the room so you don't
make this mistake again and embarrass
yourself on the freaking radio
all right we don't need to carry on with
the rest of the commentary but what
about
seriously
um
but you got to take ownership as a guy
right you know a lot of you guys in the
live chat were all over this like a fat
kid on cake and you nailed it
um
if you read this book you're going to
solve a lot of your problems chapter 3
why genuine burning desire matters
luke did not have it and luke went
chasing a girl that had
very little to no interest in him
whatsoever
she obviously i mean she stated loud and
clear she wasn't intimate with a guy
she obviously gave him no signal that
she wanted to be even though this dude
was chasing her you can't friend zone
your way into a you know woman's life
guys like you can't
you know women have girlfriends and
boyfriends if you're not banging then
guess what you are you're her girlfriend
so uh you know
what can i say guys you know you bring
the stuff on yourself throwing your time
effort and resources at women that don't
have genuine burning desire for you and
then you wonder why
and then you call in on a radio show
and you've got the [ __ ] of the year
that just like lays into you live on the
radio while you're basically pining for
her attention and then you realize oh i
now i know what happened okay i was i
was just beta bucks he didn't say it he
he said i was just mr right now but no
you weren't you didn't even get right
now wither all you got was beta bucks
so
it is what it is what it is
um you know
like you know moff nailed it like women
are ruthless they like there is there
should never ever be any confusion guys
none
like the medium is the message
watch what she says don't listen to what
she's
you know texting you oh thank you you
know i had a nice day how was your day
oh my day was a nice day how was your
day that's cool i'd like to take you out
for your birthday oh yeah i really like
this necklace here's a link to it okay
that's pretty sweet
she's not expressing genuine interest
in you then guess who was rearranging
her guts that night after you got
dropped off from your little dinner and
you know lock it giving ceremony for the
necklace
chad right not you
it is what it is what it is
i hope that's the lesson
pay attention guys
women don't ghost men that they have
genuine burning desire for you they
don't
they don't it's it's it's like very
difficult to get rid of them in the chat
i know we've got moff we've got
uh jaren in there we've got a few you
know some you know the players are in
the house basically
if women are are genuinely interested in
you like you actually have a hard time
getting rid of them like you know
getting them out of your house right so
you got to understand that
like their actions need to be paid
attention to like it should be obvious
to you like you should never think
yourself gee i don't know why she didn't
get back to me
let me think what what what is the
reason that she didn't get back to me
was it because i bought her the wrong
locket did i get her the wrong wine at
the wine tasting did i message her the
wrong thing too early in the day what
did i do wrong i know i'll call the
radio station because they do this
segment and i'll put myself on the air
and embarrass myself and you know corner
this check who clearly has no interest
in me
if you saw the code in the matrix you
wouldn't have gone through these steps
is what i'm saying right believe the
actions not the words
believe the actions not the words that's
what it all boils down to gents
you